my tip for anyone who's like I don't
even know where to start is to remind
you that inequalities behave in many
ways just like equations inequalities
behave just like equations in many ways
for instance you can see the very first
thing that was done is subtract 4 from
both sides which is just like something
you would do for an equation right after
he subtracted 4 you can see on the next
line he even said what he's done on
every step he's subtracting 2x from both
sides and that's also something you do
in the equation also fine
when he gets from that point this is a
good Co to choose he's got this this is
what he's got here minus 7x on the left
hand side is less than negative 11 okay
and so far he's just treated it like an
equation it does one last thing and this
shows one of the differences between
inequalities and equations what's he
done you can see it underneath here he
has that's that's division by negative 7
okay now here's where I'm just going to
just be careful okay because the line
that I've circled in green which mother
wrote is correct but once you include
this the division it's not correct
anymore he's fixed himself up because
what's the difference here have a look
the signed inequality has Chiefs
direction right so he knows what he's
doing however he's communicated it a
little bit blurry here because even
though this top part is right once he
applies the next bit he has to change
the inequality but this is exactly right
this is perfect so he has solved the
inequality he has made X the subject X
is bigger than 11 on seventh and here's
his number line I thought the most
important number there zero one is 11
over seven it's it's one and 4/7 right
so that's why you can see it's pretty
close to between halfway between one and
two I'm pretty happy with that
okay last little point to mention I this
circle is hollow why is that because
because that number 11 on seven is not
included if we were to change the
question how could I change the question
so your answer will have to have a
filled circle what what I do is about
yeah so if white is the beginning if it
have been this yeah it was less than or
equal to then all the way through it
would be or equal to or equal to or
equal to in which case eleven on seven
would be included and we'd color it in
so it's not which is why that's perfect
good job
okay now I'll come a look at this next
one now it's a bit tricky because when
you look at it there aren't many closing
the question if you don't remember how
to do these the question itself is not
very helpful because you're like it's
just a bunch of random gobbledygook sort
of terminology maybe you don't remember
what rationalizing means these numbers
here the square roots they are
irrational why do we call them
irrational for yeah the square root of
three you can't write as a fraction as
something over something with just whole
numbers you can get close but you can
never get exactly on okay so they're
irrational and we want to make them
rational so as well as done this okay
now this this here is a really important
step and some of us didn't remember and
what was in fact I should include the
multiplies what has she done this has a
name
she's multiplied by a particular thing
but not just any shows interesting
something randomly what is it if that's
what the feet it's the conjugate very
good so if you didn't remember that
maybe in your working you should label
that that's the conjugate in other words
it's the denominator but look it's
changed a little bit its pluses instead
of minuses okay she's done the top and
the bottom why is that why she
multiplied twice yeah if you want a
fraction to stay the same if you want a
half to stay a half then if you multiply
by a number you have to do the same to
the top and the bottom otherwise it's
not a half anymore it becomes some other
number so she's done the top of the
bottom now let's have a look at the next
line have a look at these numbers these
numbers are important when it's 40 come
from you have a look at the worker you
tell me
yeah good 5 times 8 where does 10 root 3
come from 5 times 2 or 3 so you can see
what she's doing she's um she's doing
that scene you remember you'll do it
with your hands you those double so
here's one of the pair's the first one
and from there you can see where 8 root
3 comes from you see it and you can also
see where what is that is that 3 root 3
okay so 3 root 3 should come from this
pair is through and 3 what we should get
though how can we fix that what yeah
this is root 3 times 2 root 3 so the
root threes go together and make 3 so 2
times 3 is 6 so let's just fix this up
this should be a 6
everything else is fine okay so she's
just on her numerator and that looks
really good but it's a fraction right so
what other bit do I need you've done it
so look at this denominator on the whole
thing is divided by okay now what goes
on the bottom can someone help us out
how can we complete this we could do
just what we do on the top that will
work just fine pair everything up you'll
get 4 numbers and then simplify up but
there's a reason why we chose this and
this together they were related in a
special way does anyone remember what
special relationship between them their
brain nailed a difference of two squares
this is a minus B times a plus B and
that's what does that equal when you
multiply together it's called difference
of squares so what is what is the
difference of squares
it's a squared there's a square minus B
squared it's the difference difference
between two squares okay so I just need
to work out what a squared and B squared
ah if that's a what's a squared good and
if that's B this is a bit trickier two
root three what's 2 or 3 times 2 root 3
the 2 times 2 gives you 4 the root 3
Times root of 3 gives you 3 so 4 times 3
is I heard it minus 12
there we go okay so from here we need to
tidy up a little bit but just for the
sake of time I'll complete it for you
looks like that's going to be 46 Plus
that divided by this are there any
common factors that we can take out 46
plus 18 root 3 on 52 is there any can
cancel come on this will be I can cancel
right is it aren't they all even numbers
they're all even right so I can write 23
Plus this on this and now I'm done okay
so that was tricky I guess that's what
happens when I make up numbers but there
you go I've successfully rationalized
the denominator